Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At New Balance, we believe if you run, you're a a runner however you choose to do it because when you're not worried about doing things the right way you're free to discover your way and that's what running's all about
感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在 New Balance，我们坚信，只要你跑步，你就是个跑者，无论你选择以何种方式奔跑。因为当你不再担心是否用“正确”的方式跑步时，你便能自由地去探索属于你自己的方式，而这正是跑步的真谛。
run your way at newbalance.com slash running. It's morning again in America. Today, more men and women will go to work than ever before in our country's history with interest rates at about half the record highs of 1980 nearly 2 000 families today will buy new homes more than at any time in the past four years this afternoon 6 500 young men and women will be married and with inflation of less than half of what it was just four years ago, they can look forward with confidence to the future.
在 newbalance.com/running 跑出你的专属方式。美国再次迎来清晨。今天，成千上万的男女将走向工作岗位，人数创下我国历史上的新高。随着利率回落至1980年历史最高峰的约一半，今天将有近2000个家庭买下新房，超过了过去四年中任何一个时期的水平。今天下午，将有6500对年轻男女步入婚姻殿堂。而通货膨胀率还不到仅仅四年前的一半，他们完全可以满怀信心地展望未来。
It's morning again in America. And under the leadership of President Reagan, our country is prouder and stronger and better. Why would we ever want to return to where we were less than four short years ago? Oh, heartwarming stuff there, Dominic Sandbrook. You very much wanted to open with that, which was the famous re-election advert for Reagan in the 1984 election, four years, of course, after he won against Jimmy Carter. And it's interesting listening to that, how he's still playing
美国再次迎来清晨。在里根总统的领导下，我们的国家更加自豪、更加强大、更加美好。我们怎么会想回到短短不到四年前的那种状态呢？哦，真是暖心的一幕啊，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。你非常想以这段音频开场，这正是里根在1984年竞选连任时的著名广告，当时距离他击败吉米·卡特已经过去了四年。听着这段广告很有意思，他依然在利用
off against the memories of the Carter presidency. Four years ago. Why would you want to go back to a time before morning when all is dark and gloomy and miserable and people aren't getting married and people aren't kind of hugging each other and raising flags and all that kind of stuff, which is going on in the advert. It's probably one of the most famous American ads of all time. Most famous ads tend to be negative. So the ad that Lyndon Johnson ran against Goldwater in 1964, the year that Reagan first really got involved with politics. That's the one with the little girl blowing the flower and then she gets nuked.
卡特总统时期的记忆来做文章。四年前。你为什么想回到那个清晨到来之前、万物黑暗阴郁痛苦、人们不结婚、不互相拥抱、不升国旗以及广告里那些事情都没有发生的时代呢？这可能是美国历史上最著名的广告之一。最著名的广告往往都是负面的。比如林登·约翰逊在1964年（里根真正涉足政坛的那一年）用来攻击戈德华特的广告。就是那个小女孩在吹小花然后被原子弹炸飞的广告。
Exactly. The nuclear weapons, the Daisy advert. But this is unusual in being a very famous advert that's positive. And actually, as a British historian, you watch that advert and the sense of being immersed in an enormous vat of syrup. Drowning. It's hard to resist, but it's absolutely the key to Reaganism. The emphasis on the family, the emphasis on the flag, on being stronger, prouder, stronger, better. The sort of Hollywood sheen. And the Hollywood sheen is something that is a part of Reagan's presidency right from the beginning, and it kicks off in his inauguration after his victory in 1980.
没错。核武器，雏菊广告。但这个广告很不寻常，它是一个非常著名的正面广告。事实上，作为一个英国历史学家，你看这个广告时，会有一种被浸泡在巨大糖浆缸里的感觉。灭顶之灾。这很难抗拒，但这绝对是里根主义的关键。对家庭的强调，对国旗的强调，变得更强大、更自豪、更坚强、更好。那种好莱坞的光环。而好莱坞的光环从一开始就融入了里根的总统任期，并在他1980年胜选后的就职典礼上拉开了帷幕。
So we ended last time, didn't we, by talking about how there was a real sense of, I mean, Jimmy Carter had talked of a malaise in 1979. The Americans had left Vietnam in 1973. Saigon fell in 75. The Iranian hostage crisis, high inflation, rising unemployment, a real sense of the American dream having kind of lost its way. So they go together in the limousine from the White House, Carter and Reagan. Carter, it's so richly symbolic. I mean, you said before we started recording this, that so much of it feels like people have been supplied by a Hollywood casting agency. The lines have been written by the most melodramatic script writer. And Carter has literally been up all night trying to get the hostages out of Iran. He's haggard,
所以我们上期节目结束时，谈到了那种真实的感受——我的意思是，吉米·卡特在1979年曾谈到过一种“ malaise”（萎靡不振）。美国人在1973年撤出越南。西贡在75年陷落。伊朗人质危机、高通货膨胀、不断上升的失业率，让人真切地感觉到美国梦似乎迷失了方向。因此，卡特和里根一起坐豪华轿车从白宫出发。卡特这一幕具有极其丰富的象征意义。我的意思是，你在我们录音前说过，这一切看起来就像是由好莱坞选角公司安排的人选。台词则是由最戏剧化的编剧写出来的。卡特字面意思上整晚没睡，试图把人质从伊朗救出来。他面容憔悴、
exhausted. He hasn't shaved until the very last minute he throws on his suit he gets in the limo with reagan and carter he's stricken he is a stricken man and he says nothing and reagan tries to lighten the mood by telling him jokes about how he was well there's a great there's a great joke isn't there about um what is flat and glows in the dark tehran the day after reagan's inauguration all right golly yeah well but the thing is then Reagan gets up there and he gives this inaugural address, which is very, very, it absolutely sets the tone. And he tells a story about a young man.
筋疲力尽。他直到最后一刻才刮胡子，套上西装，和里根一起坐进了豪华轿车。卡特深受打击，他是一个深受打击的人，一言不发。而里根则试图通过讲笑话来轻松一下气氛，比如有个非常棒的笑话，不是吗？关于……呃，什么东西是平的而且在黑暗中会发光？里根就职典礼第二天的德黑兰。好吧，天哪，是的。但问题是，接着里根上台发表了这篇就职演说，这篇演说非常非常……彻底定下了基调。他讲了一个年轻人的故事。
He looks out to Arlington Cemetery, which you can kind of not really see, but just see in the distance, there in the distance, National Cemetery. And he says, row and row of white markers. He tells the story of one man who lies under these markers for martin treptow who was killed in 1917 in um in the first world war and on his body was found a diary with the words he'd written my pledge in it this pledge said america must win
他望向阿灵顿公墓，虽然不能完全看清，但能隐约看到远处的那座国家公墓。他说，一排又一排白色的墓碑。他讲了长眠在这些墓碑之下的其中一个人的故事，这个人是马丁·特雷普托（Martin Treptow），他在1917年的第一次世界大战中阵亡。人们在他的遗体上发现了一本文物日记，上面写着他立下的誓言。这个誓言写道：美国必须赢得
this war i will work i will save i will sacrifice i will fight cheerfully and do my utmost, as if the issue of the whole struggle depended on me alone. Reagan tells that story and he says, you know, we are called upon to try to live up to that, to believe that we, like Martin Treptow and Co, can resolve our challenges with God's help. And he ends his final sentence, after all, why shouldn't we believe that? We are Americans. And it is so stirring and rousing. The thing is, it wasn't true. His speechwriter had said to him, I don't think we should use this because, first of all, he's not buried at Arlington National Cemetery. So the whole conceit is not true. And secondly, he probably wasn't the first person to write that pledge. He was probably writing down something that he had heard.
这场战争，我将工作，我将节省，我将牺牲，我将乐观地战斗并尽我所能，就好像整个斗争的胜负全系于我一身。里根讲完这个故事后说，你知道，我们被召唤去努力不辜负这种精神，去相信我们，就像马丁·特雷普托等人一样，在上帝的帮助下解决我们的挑战。他在最后一句结尾时说：毕竟，我们为什么不该相信这一点呢？我们是美国人。这段话极其鼓舞人心，催人奋进。问题是，这不是真的。他的演讲撰稿人曾对他说，我认为我们不应该用这个故事，因为首先，他并没有葬在阿灵顿国家公墓。所以整个艺术加工根本不是真的。其次，他可能也不是第一个写下这个誓言的人。他很可能是写下了他曾经听过的话。
East Coast liberals with their tedious facts. His scriptwriter, Ken Kachigian, who says that to him, and Reagan says to him, it's too good a story. So they leave it in. Right. And so that's the essence, isn't it? Because, I mean, it's not a kind of a barefaced lie. Well, I suppose it is to a degree, but I mean, it's not like the kind of Trump saying a million people turned up when it was about 10. It's Reagan's understanding of what is true. The kind of the mere historical details are as nothing compared to the radiance of the message that it teaches, I guess would be Reagan's perspective on it.
东海岸的自由派带着他们讨厌的事实。他的编剧肯·卡奇吉安（Ken Kachigian）对他这么说，而里根对他说，这个故事太好了。于是他们把它留下了。没错。所以这就是精髓所在，对吧？因为，我的意思是，这并非一种厚颜无耻的谎言。好吧，我想某种程度上它确实是，但我的意思是，这不像特朗普说有一百万人出现实际上只有大约10万人的那种情况。这是里根对什么是“真实”的理解。相比于它所传达的信息的光芒，纯粹的历史细节根本不值一提——我想这大概就是里根的视角吧。
That's exactly it. We talked in the previous episode about his use of parables, sort of metaphorical stories that express the kind of truth. When Reagan, I mean, we're jumping ahead, but why not? When he's in trouble with Iran-Contra, he gives this absolutely extraordinary speech where he says, I told the American people I did not trade arms for hostages. My heart and my best intentions still tell me that's true, but the facts and evidence tell me that it's not. And I think that's the essence of Reagan, that if his heart tells him something is true, then it kind of is true. So there's that. But the other thing is that the inauguration right from the start, it's a gigantic blowout. So a lot of the events at Carter's inauguration had been free and he had walked hand in hand
完全正确。我们在上一集里谈到过他对比喻的使用，也就是那些表达某种真理的隐喻性故事。当里根——我的意思是，我们有点超前了，但为什么不呢？——当他在“伊朗门”事件中陷入麻烦时，他发表了一篇极其非同寻常的演讲，他说：我曾告诉美国人民，我没有用武器换取人质。我的内心和我的最佳意愿仍然告诉我这是真的，但事实和证据告诉我并非如此。我认为这正是里根的本质，如果他的内心告诉他某件事是真的，那么它在某种程度上就是真的。所以这就是情况所在。但另一件事是，就职典礼从一开始就是一个盛大的狂欢。卡特就职典礼上的许多活动都是免费的，他曾手挽着手
with his wife, Rosalind, from the White House to the Capitol or vice versa, I can't remember which, because he wanted to show that he was a man of the people. Reagan realizes that ultimately Americans don't want that, that actually, for all the talk of the republic, they want a king, they want a monarch, and he's brilliant at playing a king. So he and Nancy are in absolutely all their finery. You pay something like, is it $10,000? I think it's $10,000 for a box at Frank Sinatra's gala on the night of the inauguration.
与妻子罗莎琳从白宫步行到国会山，或者反过来，我记不清了，因为他想表现得自己是一个平民总统。里根则意识到，美国人最终并不想要那个，实际上，尽管有种种关于共和国的言论，他们其实想要一个国王，想要一个君主，而他在扮演国王方面表现得极其出色。因此，他和南希盛装打扮。你得花上大约——是1万美元吗？我想在就职典礼当晚，去弗兰克·辛纳屈的盛会买个包厢要花1万美元。
Right. But he can do this because it's saying a way that somebody like Trump can't. I mean, Trump does do it, but it kind of causes more offense because the glamour of Hollywood is something that people want to invest in. And movie stars should have limousines and fur coats and all that kind of stuff. Yes. So although there was some disquiet about Nancy and she becomes the lightning rod for Queen Nancy. Queen Nancy. And people, I mean, the famous example is when on the same day that the federal government classifies tomato ketchup as a vegetable, as a cost-cutting exercise in school lunches, she announces that she's just spent $209,000 on China for the White House with the monogram NR.
没错。但他能这样做，是因为他表达的方式是像特朗普那样的人所做不到的。我的意思是，特朗普确实也这么干，但它往往会招致更多的反感，因为好莱坞的光环是人们渴望投入其中的东西。电影明星就该坐豪华轿车、穿皮草大衣以及诸如此类的东西。是的。因此，尽管人们对南希有些不安，她也成了“南希女王”的众矢之的。南希女王。而且——我的意思是，著名的例子就是，就在联邦政府为了削减学校午餐开支而将番茄酱归类为蔬菜的同一天，她宣布自己刚刚花了20万9千美元为白宫购买了印有NR字母组合的瓷器餐具。
So she's completely tone deaf. She makes Marie Antoinette look in touch with the streets. But Reagan himself, people quite like that in a president. So Reagan, unlike Carter, Reagan says, I will never be photographed in my shirt sleeves in the Oval Office. I will always be wearing a suit and tie. I will never dress down. Because he's playing a part. Exactly. And he plays the part brilliantly. And I guess the evidence for just how well he can play it
所以她完全缺乏对民情风向的感知。她让玛丽·安托瓦内特看起来都显得与现实社会十分贴近了。但里根本人，人们却挺喜欢总统有这一套的。所以里根不同于卡特，里根说：我绝不会在椭圆形办公室里只穿着衬衫袖子拍照。我将永远穿着西装打领带。我绝不会降低着装标准。因为他在演戏。完全正确。而且他把这个角色演得极其出色。我想，关于他能把这个角色演得有多好的证据
is the courage and the capacity for recovery that he shows after he's shot. Yeah. A few weeks after the inauguration. Yes, not even two months. Exactly right. Rawhide down. So Rawhide is his code name for the security services. He was at the Hilton in Washington, D.C., talking to building construction union members.
就是他在中枪后表现出的勇气和恢复能力。是的。在就职典礼几周后。是的，甚至不到两个月。完全没错。生皮倒下了。生皮是安全部门给他的代号。当时他在华盛顿特区的希尔顿酒店，正在向建筑工会成员发表讲话。
He leaves the hotel that afternoon through the VIP entrance and then on T Street. So it's not that far from the White House, really. Six shots ring out. His press secretary is very badly hit, Jim Brady, hits in the head and ends up in a wheelchair and a policeman is hit. And Reagan at first, it's not clear that he's been hit, is it? No. So he's bundled into this limo by the Secret Service. He thinks that the person bundling him in has crushed a rib. Yeah. They rushed to the George Washington Hospital.
那天下午，他通过贵宾通道离开酒店，来到了T街。所以离白宫其实并没有那么远。六声枪响划破空气。他的新闻秘书吉姆·布雷迪（Jim Brady）身受重伤，头部中弹，最终坐上了轮椅，还有一名警察也中弹了。起初，里根是否中弹并不明朗，对吧？没有。所以他被特勤局人员塞进了豪华轿车。他以为把他塞进去的人压断了他的肋骨。是的。他们被紧急送往乔治·华盛顿医院。
And Reagan, I was astounded because I had not really read a sort of hour-by-hour reconstruction of the assassination. But he walks into the hospital, doesn't he? Under his own steam. Could I recommend a very good rawhide down by Del Quentin Wilbur, who I met at a literary festival in Palm Springs. So the thing that strikes me about it is that it's a very dramatic incident, but all the characters and all the dialogue in it make it even more dramatic. So one of the anesthetist nurses says about the two doctors who first come when Reagan walks in, if you were to call central casting and say, send me two guys who are really nice folks and look
而里根，我感到大为震惊，因为我之前并没有真正读过关于这次暗杀事件的逐小时复盘。但他自己走进了医院，对吧？凭着他自己的力量。我能推荐一本非常不错的书吗？是由德尔·昆汀·威尔伯（Del Quentin Wilbur）写的《生皮倒下》（Rawhide Down），我是在棕榈泉的一个文学节上认识他的。所以，这件事让我印象深刻的是，这是一起非常戏剧性的事件，但其中所有的角色和所有的对话让它变得更加戏剧性。因此，麻醉护士之一在谈到里根走进来时首先赶到的两名医生时说，如果你打电话给中央选角机构说，给我派两个非常友好、看起来像外科医生的家伙来，这就是他们会派来的那两个。他们不得不剪掉里根所有的西装，所以他绝对是赤身裸体的。然后他们开始摸索。他们发现他身上确实有一颗子弹，必须接受手术。外科医生进来了，准备给他做手术。里根说了一句名言：我希望你是共和党人。而这位实际上是一名公开注册的民主党人的外科医生回答说：先生，今天我们所有人都是共和党人。完美的对话。绝对完美的台词。里根康复了。南希进来了。里根说：亲爱的，我忘了低头了。是的。
like they might be surgeons, these are the two they would send. They have to cut all Reagan's suit off so he's absolutely naked. And then they're kind of feeling around. They discover that there is in fact this bullet that he has to be operated on. The surgeon comes in and he's going to operate him. Reagan famously says, I hope you're a Republican. And the surgeon, who is in fact a card-carrying Democrat, says that today, sir, we are all Republicans. Perfect dialogue. Absolutely perfect lines. Reagan recovers. Nancy comes in. Reagan says, honey, I forgot to duck. Yeah.
他喋喋不休说个不停。护士——显然有点像简·怀曼（Jane Wyman）附体，她对里根总是一直说话感到厌烦——说：总统先生，我能用最礼貌的方式告诉您，当我把这块面巾蒙在您的眼睛上时，意思就是我希望您闭嘴。他是不是在给她讲他在《读者文摘》上读到的故事？蒂普·奥尼尔（Tip O'Neill）——他是民主党众议院议长，是的，在意识形态上与里根的做法格格不入——他走进病房，在里根的床边跪下，背诵了一首圣经诗篇。我的意思是，整个过程都被编写得如此完美，然后又增添了一种黑暗的视角：事实是，开枪射击里根的家伙约翰·欣克利（John Hinckley）迷恋上了电影明星——也就是朱迪·福斯特。他试图以此来给对方留下深刻印象。
He cannot stop talking. The nurse, who's obviously kind of channeling Jane Wyman, who was fed up with how much Reagan was always talking, says, Mr. President, in the most polite way I can tell you, when I put this face cloth over your eyes, it means I want you to shut up. Is he telling her stories about things he's read in the Reader's Digest? Tip O'Neill, who is the democrat speaker yeah very ideologically opposed to what reagan is doing he comes in kneels by reagan's bed recites one of the psalms i mean the whole thing is so kind of perfectly scripted and then adding a kind of a dark perspective on that it turns out that the guy who has shot re, John Hinckley, is obsessed with a movie star in the form of Jodie Foster. And he's trying to impress her.
因为他在一部关于刺杀的电影《出租车司机》里看过她。而《出租车司机》本身——《出租车司机》里的角色、罗伯特·德尼罗饰演的角色——原型是开枪射击乔治·华尔斯的阿瑟·布雷默（Arthur Bremer）。是的。所以这就像是一座镜厅。《生皮倒下》一书也暗示，欣克利受到了马克·大卫·查普曼（Mark David Chapman）的影响，后者在几个月前枪杀了约翰·列农。因此，那种关于名人崇拜、关于电影、关于政治戏剧的感觉——我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的镜厅。而里根从这件事中抽身出来时形象非常好，不是吗？因为——
Because he's seen her in a film about an assassination taxi driver. And Taxi Driver itself, the character of Taxi Driver, Robert De Niro's character, is based on Arthur Bremmer, who shot George Wallace. Yeah. So it's just kind of halls of mirrors. And Rawhide Dan also suggests that the Hinkley has been influenced by Mark David Chapman, who shot John Lennon just a few months before. And so the sense of celebrity, of movies, of political drama, I mean, it's an incredible hall of mirrors like that. And Reagan comes out of it very well, doesn't he? Because-
确实如此。我的意思是，他当时怎么着？虽然这时他已经七十出头了，但他是个非常健康的男人。是的。他很快就重新站起来了。不到两周他就出院了。我认为那种扮演角色的意识——尽管很容易被人嘲笑——却是他政治吸引力的一个绝对核心部分。
He does. I mean, he's what? He's in his early seventies by this point, but he's a very fit man. Yes. He's back up on his feet pretty soon. He's out within less than two weeks. I think that sense of playing a part, which is so easily derided, is an absolutely central part of his political appeal.
我们在做关于法国总统的播客时稍微讨论过这一点。法国选民会奖赏那些扮演君主制总统角色的总统，马克龙是这样，密特朗或戴高乐也是如此。我认为罗斯福在担任总统时也是这样。嗯，这正是首相和总统的区别，对吧？绝对是的。里根始终清醒地意识到自己在扮演总统。尽管他的政策往往具有高度的争议性，但他努力代表所有美国人。他经常谈论美国，谈论身为美国人的意义。他从不放松警惕。他从不取笑自己的角色。他身上没有一丝荒谬感，也没有任何挑眉弄眼的暗示。他认为美国总统的职位肩负着尊严、意义，以及一种——我敢说——神圣的重要性。
I mean, we talked about this a little bit when we did our podcast about French presidents. The French electorate reward a president who plays the part of the monarchical president, which Macron does, which Mitterrand did or de Gaulle. And I think FDR did that as president. Well, it's a difference between a prime minister and a president, isn't it? Absolutely, it is. Reagan is always conscious that he's playing the president. Although his policies are often very divisive, he tries to speak for all Americans. He talks a lot about America, about what it means to be American. He never lets his guard down. He never pokes fun at his own role. There's no hint of absurdity about him, of sort of a raised eyebrow. He thinks the American presidency is charged with dignity
嗯，确实有一种公民宗教，美国公民宗教，你可以这么说。对于里根来说，则是字面意义上的宗教。是的。我的意思是，他字面意思上是以善恶二元论来看待自己的角色，这把我们带到了他的第一任期的两个重大主题之一，我想。首先是冷战。
and meaning and a sort of, dare I say, sacral importance. Well, there is a kind of civil religion, American civil religion, I suppose you would say. And for Reagan, literal religion. Yeah. I mean, he literally sees his role in terms of good and evil, which brings us to one of the two great themes, I suppose, of his first presidency. So the first is the Cold War.
是的。第二个是经济。嗯，也许我们——他的第一任期的重大主题。首先是冷战，第二个是经济。嗯，也许我们应该从经济开始谈起。经济。好的。因为就在里根中枪并正在康复之际，经济正陷入困境。确实如此。所以他掌权时采取的政策——这跟撒切尔主义不太一样。人们总以为它和撒切尔主义是一回事，其实不然。这是一套被称为供给学派经济学的理论。或者被称为“巫术经济学”，正如曾在党内初选中作为里根对手、后来成为其副总统的乔治·布什所形容的那样。完全正确。所以供给学派，供给学派的精髓——我的意思是，我们可以花上几个小时来讨论这个，
Yeah. And the second is the economy. Well, maybe we, of his first presidency. So the first is the Cold War and the second is the economy. Well, maybe we should start with the economy. The economy. Okay. Because even as Reagan is being shot and then recovering, the economy is in trouble. It is. So he's come to power with, it's not quite the same as Thatcherism. People always think it's the same as Thatcherism, but it isn't. It's a doctrine called supply-side economics. Or voodoo economics, as George Bush, who had been Reagan's opponent in the primaries and then becomes his vice president, had put it. Exactly. So supply-side, the essence of supply-side, I mean, we could spend hours discussing this,
但它的精髓就是减税、解除管制、为企业创造更便利的生存环境，这将有助于经济复苏。事实上，当时有一条著名的曲线叫做“拉弗曲线”，是由一位名叫阿瑟·拉弗（Arthur Laffer）的经济学家在一张华盛顿餐馆的餐巾纸上画出来的。他说，如果你把税减到一定程度，你将达到这样一个临界点：经济会增长得如此之快，以至于你的税收收入实际上反而会增加。涓滴经济学。
but the essence of it is you cut taxes, you lift regulations, you make life easier for business, and that will help the economy to recover. And in fact, there was a famous curve called the Laffer curve that an economist called Arthur Laffer had drawn on a napkin in a Washington restaurant, which he said, if you cut taxes enough, you will reach a point where the economy grows so much that your tax revenues will actually go up. Trickle-down economics.
是的，这在现实中从来没有真正实现过。但如果你是个有钱人，这倒挺棒的。是的，如果你有钱，这确实很棒。事实上，许多保守派经济学家当时及以后都曾表示，这纯粹是胡扯。这其实是一个典型的里根式寓言。它深深扎根于人们的心中，比如餐巾纸上有这样一条曲线的概念。是的，人们非常喜欢这个。所以里根任命了一位预算局长，一个名叫大卫·斯托克曼（David Stockman）的年轻人。他当时34岁。他非常理想主义。他说，听着，让我们大幅削减税收。所以他们要把最高税率从70%降到50%。他们要
Yeah, this has never quite been reached in reality. But it's great if you're rich. Yeah, it's great if you're rich. In fact, a lot of conservative economists at the time and ever since have said, this is utter tosh. That's a classic Reagan-style parable, actually. It kind of lodges in people's minds, the idea that there's this curve on a napkin. Yeah. And people love that. So Reagan has this budget director, a very young man called David Stockman. He's 34. He's very idealistic. He says, listen, let's slash taxes. So they're going to bring down the top rate of tax from 70% to 50%. They're going to
普遍减税，三年内减税23%，这是一次大规模的减税。而且我们还要削减开支。事实上，里根经济学如何在实践中运作的关键在于，他们先减税，然后斯托克曼说：好啦，现在轮到削减开支了。他们砍掉了那些对共和党人来说最容易砍掉的东西。因此他们砍掉了诸如针对有工作但贫困人口的福利、食品券、学校午餐，因为在他们看来这些人拿到食品券都会跑去商店挥霍买一大堆食物。这就是里根的看法。这就是里根的看法。完全正确。
cut taxes in general, 23% in three years, a massive tax cut. And we'll also cut spending. And actually the key to how Reaganomics works in practice is they cut the taxes and then Stockman says, right, now for the spending. They cut the easy things, easy for Republicans. So they cut things like welfare for the working poor, food stamps, school lunches, because they're all just going out and blowing all their food stamps on enormous amounts of food in shops. This is the Reagan take. That's the Reagan take. Exactly.
他们说，把这些统统砍掉。当然他们可以砍掉这些，因为这并不是真正的共和党选民基本盘。这可以说就是唾手可得的低垂果实。然后他们说，那——斯托克曼问，那社会保障呢？哦，不，那个不能砍。接着他发现，哦，我们还得大幅增加国防开支。于是他们将国防开支从刚超过总开支的20%提高到了近30%。直接把它拉回了越南战争期间他们真正在打仗时的水平。到了第一年年底，斯托克曼接受了《大西洋月刊》的采访，在采访中他说：事实上，这个宏伟的计划根本没有奏效，因为我意识到政府根本不愿意削减开支。里根实际上要做的是减税，然后通过借钱来把钱花在国防上。本质上，情况就是这样。因此到了1982年，财政赤字达到了1280亿美元。到1983年，赤字已经飙升至2070亿美元，这是美国历史上绝无仅有的和平时期最大财政赤字。所以这正是里根与撒切尔夫人的不同之处。撒切尔夫人非常注重平衡预算。她实际上——
They say, well, cut all that. And of course they can cut them because that's not really the Republican constituency. That's, as it were, low-hanging fruit. Then they say, what about, Stockman's like, well, what about social security? Oh, no, you can't cut that. And then he discovers, oh, we're also going to have a massive increase in defense spending. So they increased defense spending from just over 20% of spending to almost 30%. Take it right back up to where it was in the Vietnam War, when they're actually fighting a war. By the end of that first year, Stockman gives an interview to the Atlantic Monthly in which he says, actually, this great plan hasn't
持家之道。是的，精打细算。事实上，当她陷入困境时她甚至会加税，因为她的核心理念就是削减借贷。里根借起钱来就像没有明天一样。而他之所以在某种程度上负担得起，是因为美元是储备货币。没错，因为美国经济太强劲了。所以这就是罗纳德·里根与比如莉兹·特拉斯之间的区别。是的，你看，莉兹·特拉斯，英国的莉兹·特拉斯当时想复制里根经济学。但即使在当时，人们也说：是的，但这招对英国不管用。美国人凭借他们庞大的经济体量和在世界上的超大角色可以蒙混过关，但我们不行。与此同时，美联储主席保罗·沃尔克（Paul Volcker）——他是由吉米·卡特任命的——对对抗通货膨胀非常感兴趣，因此他把利率推高了，在1981年夏天达到了20%的峰值。
really worked out at all because I've realized that the administration is not prepared to cut spending. That actually what Reagan's going to do is he's going to cut taxes and just borrow money to spend on defense. In essence, this is what happens. So in 1982, the deficit is $128 billion. By 1983, it's already gone up to $207 billion, by far the greatest peacetime deficits in American history. So this is what makes it different from Mrs. Thatcher. Mrs. Thatcher is very much, she really believes in kind of a balanced budget. She in fact- Housekeeping. Yeah, good housekeeping. She in fact raises taxes when she gets into trouble because she's all about cutting borrowing.
每一个听到这里的人大概都能猜到，如果你拥有高利率，借钱就会变得非常昂贵。你会遭遇一场巨大的经济衰退。因此，经济在1981至1982年陷入衰退，300万个工作岗位流失。其中许多岗位位于所谓的“铁锈地带”。而且这些工作岗位往往再也不会回来了。所以如果你身在底特律，身在密歇根，身在——我不知道，宾夕法尼亚或俄亥俄或其他地方，如果你身处一个工厂城市，这些就是真正在里根执政时期遭受苦难的地方。弗林特。密歇根州的弗林特。
Reagan borrows money like there's no tomorrow. Which he can kind of afford to do because the dollar is the reserve currency. Right, because the American economy is so strong. So that's the difference between Ronald Reagan and Liz Truss, for instance. Yes, well, Liz Truss, you see, Liz Truss in Britain wanted to kind of reproduce Reaganomics. And even at the time, people said, yeah, but it doesn't work that way for Britain. The Americans can get away with this, with this gigantic economy and their outsized role in the world but we can't now meanwhile the head of the federal reserve paul volcker who'd been appointed by under jimmy carter he is really interested in fighting inflation so he has increased interest rates hit a peak of 20
是的，迈克尔·摩尔曾制作过一个节目，不是吗？关于密歇根州的弗林特。我的意思是，这些地方曾经是罗斯福总统的美国的中流砥柱——发动机舱。而里根这位罗斯福的狂热信徒、狂热爱好者，却正在摧毁这一切。是的。我的意思是，你可以争辩说，而且完全有理由争辩说：由于全球化，这个世界无论如何都是注定要没落的。但里根——尽管不如英国的撒切尔夫人那么彻底，
in the summer of 1981 everybody listening to this can probably guess what happens if you have high interest rates, it's very expensive to borrow money. You get a massive recession. So the economy goes into recession in 81, 82, 3 million jobs are lost. A lot of those in the kind of rust belt. And those are jobs often that don't return. So if you're in Detroit, if you're in Michigan, if you're in, I don't know, Pennsylvania or Ohio or somewhere, and you're in a factory town, these are the places that really suffer in the Reagan years. Flint. Flint, Michigan.
但在某种程度上，里根成了这种变化的化身，成了那种痛苦变革的面孔。我认为让它在美国显得如此情绪激昂、在英国没有引起同样强烈共鸣的原因是，里根政府实在太浮华了。就在发生这一切的同时，南希却在购买全新的中国瓷器、穿着昂贵的礼服。这种对比是如此鲜明。那么，他们是如何从经济衰退和飞涨的赤字，转变为能够宣称“美国再次迎来清晨”并抛出一系列如此亮眼的数据的呢？首先，他们在“美国再次迎来清晨”的广告中根本没有提及赤字，因为财政赤字在整个20世纪80年代一直在持续。所以他们把这一点轻描淡写地掩盖过去了。
Yeah. Michael Moore did a program, didn't he, about Flint, Michigan. I mean, these are places that have been the backbone- The engine room. Of FDR's America. And Reagan, the great disciple of the great enthusiast of FDR, is destroying it. Yes. I mean, you could argue, I think you can argue quite reasonably, this is a world that is doomed anyway because of globalization. But Reagan, not as much as Mrs. Thatcher in Britain,
他们把这事糊弄过去了。直到乔治·布什——他不得不加税——以及90年代的比尔·克林顿上台后，他们才开始着手基本上消除这个赤字。失业率在1982年底达到了约11%的峰值，这与英国类似，比率差不多，但随后迎来了巨大的经济繁荣，而这是英国所没有的。英国当时也有一点繁荣，但规模远不如美国。究竟是什么刺激了这种繁荣？我知道我们试图在这期播客里塞进太多内容，所以我得尽量长话短说。我认为这取决于你问的是谁，汤姆。这取决于他们的政治立场。所以，一个自由派经济学家，
but to some extent, Reagan becomes the face of it, the face of that change. And I think what makes it so charged in the United States, it doesn't quite have the same resonance in Britain, is that the Reagan administration is so glitzy. And that at the same time this is happening, Nancy is buying all the new China and wearing expensive dresses. And there's that contrast, it's so marked. So how do they go from the recession and this ballooning deficit to being able to say it's morning in America and all these great statistics. Well, first of all, they don't mention the deficit in the morning again in America advert because the deficit continues throughout the 1980s. So they're skating over that.
比如保罗·克鲁格曼，会认为繁荣无论如何都会到来。这是商业周期的一部分。实际上，里根所做的是——80年代初本来就注定会有一场经济衰退。他只是在顺应由于技术变革、由于不可避免的复苏而必然会到来的繁荣浪潮。美国其实拥有许多潜在的优势。卡特的“萎靡”被夸大了，美国经济本来就会蓬勃发展，而且石油价格也大幅下跌。
They skate over that. And it's actually not till George Bush, who has to raise taxes, and then Bill Clinton in the 1990s, they start to basically eliminate that deficit. The unemployment rate peaks at about 11% at the end of 82, similar to Britain, similar rate, but then there's a huge boom and that doesn't really have a British. There is a bit of a boom in Britain, but it's much bigger in America. What is stimulating the boom? I know we're trying to pack so much into this podcast, so I'm going to have to try to really boil it down. I think it depends who you ask, Tom. So it depends on their politics. So a liberal economist,
所以繁荣来了。如果你是一个更加亲里根的经济学家，你会说减税是其中很大一部分原因。减税意味着人们口袋里有了更多的钱，人们可以投资，企业可以投资，放松管制意味着会有更多的竞争。好吧。因此，放松管制——我们再次谈到，这位罗斯福的信徒最终是如何将所有这些破坏施加给新政的旧腹地的。还有另一项著名的政策背叛了里根的直觉教养，我们在上一集提到过，里根是唯一一位曾担任过工会领袖的总统。哦，对的。是的。他把所有的空中交通管制员都解雇了，不是吗？他确实这么做了。帕科（PATCO）。帕科是那个工会的名称。作为联邦雇员，空中交通管制员是不被允许罢工的。这可以追溯到20世纪50年代，后来得到了肯尼迪总统的再次确认。空中交通管制员要求更高的薪酬，显然，在通货膨胀、高通胀时期，人们总是会这么做。他们想要更多报酬，但也想要更好的工作条件。他们对自己的工作条件感到非常不满。他们说自己
somebody like Paul Krugman, would say that boom is coming anyway. It's part of the business cycle. Actually, what Reagan is doing is there was always going to be a recession in the early 80s. He's surfing the boom that is inevitably going to come
压力非常大。我记得他们想要实行四天工作制。联邦政府向他们提供11.4%的涨薪。必须承认，这实际上比他们提供给大多数联邦雇员的涨幅还要高。他们说这根本不行。他们决定他们提供给大多数联邦雇员的涨幅还要高。他们说这根本不行。他们决定不管怎样都要罢工。而里根基本上说：你们有48小时。如果在48小时内不回来上班，我就开除你们。我想他们当时并不相信他会动真格。结果他真的把他们全开除了。接着他找了军方人员来替代他们。实际上，这立下了一个非常有力的标杆：他绝不容忍工会的任何无理取闹。他会雷厉风行地做他必须做的事。
because of technological change, because of the inevitable recovery. America's actually got lots of underlying strengths. The carton malaise was oversold and the economy is always going to be booming and also oil prices are very i've dropping i've dropped so the boom now if you're a more pro-reagan economist you would say the tax cut is a big part of it the tax cut means people have more money in their pockets people can invest businesses can invest deregulation means there's more competition. Okay. So the deregulation, again, we're talking about how the disciple of FDR ends up inflicting
显然，如果你不喜欢里根，如果你属于左翼，如果你身在工会，这会被视为一种令人发指的行径。如果你属于右翼，你会说：哦，这难道不是伟大、大胆的领导力吗，诸如此类。有趣的是，他不仅解雇了他们，还终身禁止他们从事联邦工作。哇，我之前没意识到这一点。这后来被克林顿取消了。还有一种类似的、我猜也是一种类似的果断或固执——无论你根据自己的政治立场如何去解读——体现在他的外交政策上。
all this damage on the old heartlands of the New Deal. And the other famous policy that betrays Reagan's instinctive upbringing, we mentioned in the previous episode that Reagan is the only president to have been a union leader. Oh, right. Yes. He sacks all the air traffic controllers, doesn't he? He does. The PACCO. PACCO is the name of the union. So as federal employees, air traffic controllers are not allowed to go on strike. That dates back to the 1950s and then was reaffirmed by President Kennedy. The air traffic controllers demand higher pay, obviously, as people always do in a period of inflation, high inflation. They want more pay, but they also want better working conditions. They're very aggrieved about their working conditions. They say they're
在苏联人看来，这是直接对抗性的；而在我长大的索尔兹伯里，也绝对是这种感觉。北约总部就在我长城郊外不远的地方，也就是我长大的地方附近，那里有北约的区域总部。关于巡航导弹和重新武装的消息。这一切都让人感到非常不安。好吧，这也是一个复杂的故事。因此，在20世纪70年代末，苏联在其铁幕一侧部署了名为SS-20的新型导弹。欧洲方面则呼吁美国加强其军事存在，尤其是西德和英国。因此，里根的政策是——借用戈德华特的一句名言——他信仰“通过实力实现和平”。他认为你决不能退缩，共产主义是邪恶的。
very stressed. They want to move to a four-day week, I think it is. The federal government offers them 11.4%. It's actually more than they're offering most federal employees, I have to say. They say it's no good. They decide they're offering most federal employees, I have to say. They say it's no good. They decide they're going to go on strike anyway. And Reagan basically says, you have 48 hours. If you don't come back to work in 48 hours, I will fire you. I think they don't believe him. And he fires them. And then he gets people from the military to do it. And actually, it lays down a really potent marker that he's not going to take any grief from the unions. He's going to do what he has to do.
大棒政策，温言在手，大棒随身。没错。他在1983年向一个福音派团体发表了那次非常著名的演讲，其中他说苏联是一个“邪恶帝国”，是现代世界邪恶的焦点。他在英国议会发表的演讲中说
Obviously, if you don't like Reagan, if you're on the left, if you're in the unions, it's seen as outrageous. If you're on the right, you say, oh, isn't this great, bold leadership and all that sort of thing. Interestingly, he doesn't just fire them. They're banned from federal jobs for life. Wow, I didn't realize that. That was then rescinded by Clinton. And a similar, I guess, a kind of similar decisiveness or headstrongness, whatever you want to frame it, depending on your politics, about his foreign policy,
在1982年，自由与民主的进行曲将把马克思列宁主义扫进历史的垃圾堆。这是一个意象：垃圾堆。
which is, as seen from the Soviet Union, directly confrontational and definitely seen from Salisbury, where I grew up. And we have the NATO headquarters just outside, regional headquarters just outside where I grew up. News about cruise missiles and rearmament. It's all very unsettling. Well, again, it's a complicated story. So the Soviet Union at the end of the 1970s was stationing new missiles called the SS-20s on its side of the Iron Curtain. And from Europe, there are calls for the US to boost its presence, particularly West Germany and Britain. So Reagan's policy is he believes in, to borrow a Goldwaterism, peace through strength. He thinks you don't back down, communism is evil.
历史那冒烟的、带有放射性的废墟垃圾堆。他们在英国部署了巡航导弹，在西德、意大利、荷兰等地部署了潘兴导弹，诸如此类。必须说明的是，这是应这些政府的要求而部署的。并不是说有人强迫他们接受这些导弹。
Talk softly, carry a big stick. Right. He makes the very famous speech to a group of evangelicals in 83 where he says Soviet Union is an evil empire the focus for evil in the modern world. He says in an address to Parliament in Britain
当然。里根在这个时期（第一任期）最有趣的地方在于，所有人都说他是战争贩子。他随时准备按下核按钮。而你在之前的播客中也说过……好吧，还有那张贴在每个学生宿舍墙上的著名海报，那是把里根和撒切尔比作《乱世佳人》中经典的形象。上面写着什么来着？
in 1982 the march of freedom and democracy will leave Marxism Leninism on the ash heap of history. That's an image that Ash heap.
她请求他带她去世界的尽头。他说他来安排。诸如此类的话。然而，所有人都看错了里根。这绝对是最迷人的一点。里根对核武器的着迷程度达到了任何其他总统都无法企及的程度，但他对核武器有着一种深深的恐惧。我的意思是，这会让许多听众大吃一惊。
The smouldering radioactive heap of history. And they station cruise missiles in Britain, Pershing missiles in West Germany and Italy and Holland and so on and so forth. At the request, it has to be said of those governments. It's not like they're being forced to take them.
这很可能是许多听众听到后会说“他们疯了”的一点。里根其实是一个核裁军主义者。他热爱摆脱核武器的想法。这也是为什么他对“星球大战”——也就是战略防御计划——的想法如此感兴趣的原因，这个计划旨在通过太空激光建立一个保护美国的盾牌，等等诸如此类。而他自己的幕僚却对他说：这太疯狂了。他们说这会摧毁西方同盟。如果你只为美国建立一个保护盾，他们的盟友将会极其愤怒。我们从他的日记中得知，他确实在深夜因为核武器而吓出一身冷汗，在冰冷的汗水中难以入眠。正因如此，他从长远来看，
Of course. The funny thing about Reagan in this period, in the first term, is everybody says he's a warmonger. He wants to press the button. And you said in that previous podcast... Well, and the famous poster, which is on the wall of every student, is Gone with the Wind of Reagan and Thatcher evoking the famous image. What's it say?
才会承诺也将这项技术提供给苏联。是的。这就解释了为什么这个被其对手视为冷战分子化身、一个好战的挥舞着核导弹的牛仔似的人物，会主动带头，为什么他会与戈尔巴乔夫进行一系列非同寻常的峰会。
She asked him to take her to the end of the world. He said he'd organise it. Something like that. And yet, everybody got Reagan wrong. That's the absolutely fascinating thing. Reagan is obsessed with nuclear weapons to a degree unmatched by any other president, but he has a horror of nuclear weapons. I mean, this will amaze a lot of listeners.
其长远结果是一个不可思议的裁军进程。是的，我们可以看到这一点，汤姆，甚至在戈尔巴乔夫上台之前就已经开始了。因此，在1983年10月，里根观看了电影《次日》（The Day After）。我们的许多美国听众都会熟悉《次日》这部关于核浩劫的电视电影。在英国，与之对应的是《浩劫后》（Threads），实际上要吓人得多。但里根看了《次日》后，在日记中写道，他发现这部电影令人沮丧且毛骨悚然。许多保守派评论员当时在说：哦，这是左翼宣传。里根可没有这么说。他说：哦，这太可怕了。接着，几周后他发现举行了一场北约军事演习“优秀射手”（Abel Archer），而苏联人对此感到无比恐慌，以为这会引发第三次世界大战。
This is probably the one thing that a lot of listeners will say, they've gone mad. Reagan is a nuclear disarmer. He loves the thought of getting rid of nuclear weapons. It's one reason why he's so interested in the idea of Star Wars, the strategic defense initiative of a shield that will protect America with lasers in space and all this. And his own staff say to him, it's mad. They say it'll destroy the Western alliance. If you just have a shield just for the United States, their allies will be outraged. He genuinely, we know from his diary, he genuinely lies awake at night in a sort of cold sweat about nuclear weapons. And so this is why he, in the long run,
这是通过戈迪耶夫斯基——那名叛逃到英国的苏联情报人员——得知的。正是通过奥列格·戈迪耶夫斯基（Oleg Gordievsky）。里根在他的日记中写道，我们应该告诉他们，这里没有人有任何意图去做那样的事。他说：我很想把一个苏联最高领导人单独关在一个房间里，试图让他相信我们对苏联没有任何企图，俄罗斯人没有什么好怕我们的。
will pledge to offer the technology to the Soviet Union as well. Yes. And it explains why this man who is associated, you know, I mean, is seen by his opponents as the epitome of a cold warrior, a kind of gung-ho nuclear missile-wielding cowboy, why he will take the lead, why the succession of extraordinary summits with Gorbachev.
这可不是他的批评者们能想象他写得出来的话。这听起来几乎有点像——天真烂漫的孩子气。是的，确实如此。要是我能和他们共处一室，我就能说服他们。这种话是一个受过高等教育、精于国际事务分析的资深分析师在几百万年里也绝对不敢说出口的。他们会表现得过于愤世嫉俗而绝不会说这种话。完全正确。但里根没有那种背景，他拥有的那种背景是——坚信
The long-term result of that is an incredible process of dearmament. Yeah, we can see that, Tom, even before Gorbachev comes in. So in October 1983, Reagan watches The Day After. Lots of our American listeners will be familiar with The Day After, this sort of TV movie about a nuclear holocaust. So in Britain, the equivalent was Threads, which was actually much more frightening. But Reagan watched The Day After and he wrote in his diary that he found it depressing and chilling. Lots of conservative commentators were saying, oh, this is left-wing propaganda. Reagan doesn't say that at all. He says, oh, this is terrible. Then he finds out a few weeks later that there's been a NATO war game, Abel Archer, and that the Russians have really been terrified by this and thought it was going to be World War III.
善良终将胜利，生活本质上是乐观的。还有他个人的迷人魅力。他心想，只要我能走进去，和他们谈谈，我就能说服他们美国的生活方式更好。是的。只要我能向他们展示加利福尼亚所有的游泳池——当然从长远来看他确实会这么做。无论如何，这为他的第二任期做好了非常棒的铺垫。我想这集节目的下半部分……所以我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将进入里根的第二任期。
Because that's through Gordievsky, the Soviet defector to Britain. Through Oleg Gordievsky, exactly. And Reagan writes in his diary, he says, we ought to tell them that no one here has any intention of doing anything like that. He says, I would love to get a top Soviet leader in a room alone and try to convince him that we had no designs on the Soviet Union and that the Russians had nothing to fear from us.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
Now, that's not something that his critics would imagine him writing. That's sort of almost slightly sort of boyish. Yes, it is. If only I could be in the room with them, I could persuade them. It's the kind of thing that a very educated, sophisticated analyst of international affairs would never in a million years dare say. They'd be far too cynical to say that. Exactly. But Reagan doesn't have that kind of background, but he has the kind of background, well, in the kind of ideals that
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。现在是1985年。美国再次迎来了清晨，汤姆。美国再次迎来了清晨。我们已经进入了里根的第二任期。你在这期播客里真的不打算提一下沃尔特·蒙代尔（Walter Mondale）吗？不，我绝不提沃尔特·蒙代尔。这太令人震惊了。
good will triumph and that life is ultimately optimistic. And his own personal charm. He thinks, if I can just get in there, I can talk to them and I can persuade them the American way of life is better. Yeah. If I can just show them all the swimming pools in California, which of course in the long run he will do. Anyway, so that sets up his second term very nicely. And I think the second half of this episode. So I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, we will be into Reagan's second term.
善良终将胜利，生活归根结底是乐观的。凭借他个人的魅力，他认为，只要我能进去，我就能和他们对话，就能说服他们美国的生活方式更好。是的，只要我能让他们看到加州所有的游泳池，当然从长远来看他确实会这么做。总之，这就为他的第二任期做好了很好的铺垫。我想这集的前半部分就到这里。所以我想我们现在应该休息一下。等我们回来时，将进入里根的第二任期。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. It's 1985. It's morning again in America, Tom. It's morning again in America. We're into Reagan's second term. Are you not going to mention Walter Mondale in this podcast at all? No, I'm not going to mention Walter Mondale. That is shocking.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史至上》。现在是1985年。汤姆，美国又是一个美好的早晨了。美国又是一个美好的早晨。我们进入了里根的第二任期。你在这个播客里真的不打算提沃尔特·蒙代尔了吗？不，我不打算提沃尔特·蒙代尔。这太令人震惊了。
No, we're going to pass over him. So Reagan has steamrolled at Walter Mondale because the economy is in recovery uh walter mondale is a union man he belongs to the kind of new deal past this is the famous line isn't it about how he's not going to take advantage of his opponent's youth brilliant reagan i mean even if you hate reagan if you can't stand his policies you know if your job was destroyed in michigan something, it's hard to watch that debate where everybody has been saying Reagan's too old. He did a very poor performance in the first debate. Then it comes up in debate number two, and he says, I will not make age an issue in this campaign. I will not exploit for political purposes my opponent's youth and inexperience. And if you
不，我们要跳过他。因此，里根以压倒性优势击败了沃尔特·蒙代尔，因为经济正在复苏，呃，沃尔特·蒙代尔是个工会人，他属于那种新政过去的路线。这是那句名言，对吧？关于他不会利用对手年轻的优势，里根真是太绝了。我的意思是，即使你讨厌里根，如果你无法忍受他的政策，你知道的，如果你在密歇根州的工作被毁了之类的事情，看那场辩论会变得很艰难，因为每个人都说里根太老了。他在第一场辩论中的表现非常糟糕。然后到了第二场辩论，他说：“我不会在这场竞选中把年龄当作问题。我不会为了政治目的去剥削我对手的年轻和缺乏经验。”如果你
watch Mondale in that, Mondale bursts out laughing. He finds it very funny. And Mondale himself always says, that's the point. I knew I could never beat him. The Teflon quality. It's a homer. Yes, it is a homer. I'll tell you one thing that is a definite shadow of a Reagan's record, and that's AIDS. Yes.
看蒙代尔当时的反应，蒙代尔突然大笑起来。他觉得这非常有趣。而且蒙代尔自己总是说：“就是那一刻。我知道我永远无法击败他。”那种特氟龙般的特质。这真是一个全垒打。是的，确实是个全垒打。我要告诉你的一件事，那是里根政绩中明确的阴影，那就是艾滋病。是的。
So AIDS becomes more and more of an issue as time goes on. I mean, going right the way back to his governorship in California, isn't one of his key aides destroyed in a kind of gay sex scandal? That's right. Yes. I mean, no one's ever really got to the truth of that, whether it was true or whether it was just... I mean, Reagan's aides always... He's a very, very weak leader. It's a weird thing about Reagan, actually. He projects so much strength, but all his aides, all these people who we don't have time to talk about, Michael Dever and Lynn Nofsiger and, I don't know, Ed Meese and all these characters, Don Regan, they spend so much time feuding with each other and constantly being fired, resigning, coups, because they all say, and they all without exception say, Reagan hated managing people. He hated confrontation. He hated giving people bad news,
因此，随着时间的推移，艾滋病越来越成为一个问题。我的意思是，追溯到他担任加州州长的时候，他的一位核心幕僚不是在一个同性恋性丑闻中身败名裂了吗？没错。是的。我的意思是，从来没有人真正弄清过那件事的真相，到底是真是假，还是仅仅……我的意思是，里根的幕僚总是……他是一个非常、非常软弱的领导人。关于里根，实际上有一件很奇怪的事。他表现出如此强大的力量，但他的所有幕僚，所有这些我们没时间一一谈及的人——迈克尔·德弗、林恩·诺夫齐格，还有，我不知道，埃德·梅斯和所有这些角色，唐·里根——他们花了大量时间互相争斗，不断被解职、辞职、发生政变，因为他们都说，而且毫无例外地都说，里根讨厌管理人员。他讨厌对抗。他讨厌把坏消息告诉别人，
telling people off, all that sort of thing, which meant that his administration was something. It's extraordinary when you read the accounts how much of a snake pit it all is, as they're using Nancy against each other and ganging up and making accusations. But anyway, yes, I got off piece there. AIDS. There are people in the administration who say we should speak out about this, use the power of the sort of bully pulpit. His Surgeon General, who we're talking about people with amazing names, he's called Everett Coop.
责备别人，诸如此类的事情，这意味着他的政府在某种程度上……当你阅读那些记录时，会觉得这一切简直是个蛇坑，这是极其惊人的，他们利用南茜互相攻击，结党营私，互相指责。不过，言归正传，是的，我刚才跑题了。艾滋病。政府里有人说我们应该对此大声疾呼，利用类似道德制高点的力量。他的卫生局局长——我们在说那些名字很酷的人——他叫埃弗レット·库普。
Of course he is. And Everett Coop is a man of intense moral sort of religious conservatism. So Everett Coop is a cut from it. Like I've cast the agency. So he's not in favour of sodomy. He is not in favour of sodomy. However, Everett Coop is a man of great integrity. He's led by the science, as it were. And he wants the administration to support him in a sort of public awareness campaign. So that's the interesting thing, isn't it? Because de facto Christians could turn either way. I mean, they could be, these are all sodomites and it's God's plague and all that kind
当然是的。埃弗レット·库普是一个具有强烈道德感和宗教保守主义色彩的人。所以埃弗レット·库普是一个与之格格不入的人。就像我塑造的那个机构一样。所以他不支持鸡姦。他不支持鸡姦。然而，埃弗レット·库普是一个非常正直的人。可以说是听从科学的指引。他希望政府在某种公众宣传运动中支持他。所以这很有趣，不是吗？因为实质上的基督徒可能会走向任何一个极端。我的意思是，他们可能是：这些全都是鸡姦者，这是上帝的天灾，诸如此类
of stuff. Or this is a terrible catastrophe and we have a moral duty. You know, these are our citizens. Yes. That's the Everett Coop position. Well, okay. So I think the better of him then. But the Reagan will not touch it. Is that because personal morality or is that his sense that it wouldn't play well in, I don't know, certain key constituencies? I think it wouldn't play well. I think there are aides who say you don't touch it, aides who are very in with the religious right. I think Nancy is against him touching it.
的东西。或者：这是一场可怕的灾难，我们有道德责任。你知道，这些是我们的公民。是的。这就是埃弗レット·库普的立场。好吧，那么。我对他的看法有所改观了。但里根就是不肯碰这个话题。这是因为个人道德，还是他觉得这在——我不知道——某些关键选民群体中不会受欢迎？我认为这不会受欢迎。我认为有些幕僚说你不能碰这个，有些幕僚与宗教右翼走得很近。我认为南茜也反对他碰这个。
So there are stories that when Rock Hudson died in October 1985, Nancy blocked requests from Rock Hudson's publicist for the president to help move him to a French military hospital. Reagan's own aides asked him to include references to aides in the presidential addresses, wasn't it? Yeah, in the 1986 State of the Union. Yeah. And he takes it out. And he could have done it. The Thatcher government in Britain, you and I will remember, Tom, all those leaflets and the huge campaign about- Yes, the tombstone.
因此有传言称，1985年10月罗克·赫德森去世时，南茜曾阻止罗克·赫德森的公关人员提出的请求，即希望总统协助将他转移到法国的一家军事医院。里根自己的幕僚曾请求他在总统演讲中加入关于艾滋病的内容，不是吗？是的，在1986年的国情咨文中。是的。而他把它删掉了。他本可以这么做的。英国的撒切尔政府，你我都记得，汤姆，那些传单和关于——是的，墓碑。
The tombstone and all the campaign about condoms and don't die of ignorance, all this kind of thing. The Reagan administration does nothing similar. So that is a blot then. That's a blot. And another blot is the state of play with Iran and Nicaragua. So, Dominic. I've been dreading the appearance of this in the podcast because it's so complicated.
墓碑以及关于安全套和“不要死于无知”的大规模宣传，所有这些事情。里根政府没有做任何类似的事情。所以这算是一个污点。这是一个污点。另一个污点是对伊朗和尼加拉瓜的政策现状。所以，多米尼克。我一直很害怕这个话题出现在播客里，因为它太复杂了。
Okay, well, don't go too much into the detail of it. Do you want me to try and boil it down? Yeah. So there are two elements. It's not a hydra. It's a two-headed scandal. But the complicating thing is the two heads end up sort of eating each other.
好吧，那不要深入探讨太多细节。你希望我试着把它浓缩一下吗？行。所以有两个要素。这不是九头蛇。这是一个双头丑闻。但复杂的地方在于，这两个头最后互相吞噬了。
So the first thing is the Reagan administration is absolutely obsessed with Central America. Because it's their backyard. It's their backyard. And they think in the 70s, the governments of the 70s, the administration in the 70s, we're far too lax about the spread of communism. Central America, we make a stand.
所以第一件事是，里根政府对中美洲简直着迷了。因为那是他们的后院。那是他们自己的后院。他们认为在70年代，70年代的政府，70年代的政权，对共产主义的蔓延太宽容了。在中美洲，我们要表明立场。
We support the government of El Salvador. There are a load of people from Nicaragua who are helping the El Salvadorians, including the government of Nicaragua, who are these people who are left-wing called the Santinistas. They decide to encourage some rebels against the Nicaraguan government, the Santinistas, and the rebels are called the Contras. And they kind of fund them, and they slightly invent the Contras.
我们支持萨尔瓦多的政府。有一大群来自尼加拉瓜的人在帮助萨尔瓦多人，其中包括尼加拉瓜政府，也就是被称为“桑地诺阵线”的这群左翼分子。他们决定鼓励一些反抗尼加拉瓜政府（即桑地诺阵线）的叛军，这些叛军被称为“康特拉”（Contras）。他们向他们提供资金，并且在某种程度上可以说是他们创造了“康特拉”。
I mean, the Contras would have existed anyway, but they give them loads of money. Reagan creates a fantasy image of the Contras. He says they're the heirs to the Founding Fathers and the French resistance, which I think would be a great surprise to anybody in Nicaragua. Anyway, Congress is trying to roll back the power of what it sees as the imperial presidency. They've gone such a mess in Vietnam, and they don't want to get into another Vietnam and Central America. So they pass two amendments, the Boland amendments, that basically prohibits the federal government giving money to the Contras.
我的意思是，“康特拉”本来也会存在，但他们给了他们大量的资金。里根对“康特拉”产生了一种幻想般的印象。他说他们是建国先父和法国抵抗运动的继承者，我想这会对尼加拉瓜的任何人造成巨大的惊吓。无论如何，国会正试图削减它所视为的帝王式总统的权力。他们在越南吃了那么大的亏，不想在中美洲再卷入另一个越南。因此，他们通过了两项修正案——博兰修正案，基本上禁止联邦政府向“康特拉”提供资金。
They want to roll this back. Reagan says to his national security team, a guy called Bud McFarlane, his national security advisor from October 1983, it'd be great if we could find some way of getting around that to give the Contras some money. And they do. So McFarlane and a guy who works for him called Oliver North, who is described by one of his own colleagues as 30% to 50% bullshit. Yeah. Bullshit and beefcake. Exactly.
他们想要扭转这一局面。里根对他的国家安全团队说——一个叫巴德·麦克法兰的人，他从1983年10月起担任国家安全顾问——如果我们能找到某种方法绕过这个限制给“康特拉”一些资金，那就太好了。他们真的这么做了。于是麦克法兰和一个为他工作名叫奥利弗·诺斯的人——他被他的一位同事形容为有30%到50%的废话。是的。废话和健美先生。没错。
So they're both Vietnam veterans, actually, both Marines, McFarlane and North. They decide, well, we're probably not bound by this congressional thing. We can get money from our allies. So they get money from the Saudis, a Saudi royal family, give them some money, some others, and they run this slightly shambolic operation to fly weapons to the Contras, which is illegal.
所以他们实际上都是越战老兵，都是海军陆战队员，麦克法兰和诺斯。他们决定，嗯，我们可能不受国会这一规定的约束。我们可以从盟友那里得到资金。于是他们从沙特人那里弄到了钱，沙特王室给他们提供了一些资金，还有其他人，他们运行了这个略显混乱的行动，用飞机把武器运给“康特拉”，这是非法的。
I mean, to give you a sense of the shambolic nature of it, at one point the Sultan of Brunei gives them $10 million, but they gave him the wrong bank account. Have you seen this? They gave him the wrong bank account. Have you seen this? They gave him the wrong bank account. So an unidentified anonymous Swiss businessman suddenly discovered that he had a $10 million transfer from the Sultan of Brunei.
我的意思是，为了让你了解这种混乱的程度，有一次文莱苏丹给了他们1000万美元，但他们把银行账号给错了。你看到过这个吗？他们给了错误的银行账号。你看到过这个吗？他们给了错误的银行账号。因此，一个未具名的匿名瑞士商人突然发现自己收到了来自文莱苏丹的1000万美元转账。
Did they get it back? Well, he unbelievably, very public-spirited, contacted the Swiss authorities and said, I've got all this money. I think it's a right back. I mean, if I was him, I would be on an island. I'd just run off with all of Norse money. So there's that.
他们把钱拿回来了吗？嗯，他难以置信地、非常富有公共精神地联系了瑞士当局，说：“我收到了所有这些钱。我想这应该退回去。”我的意思是，如果我是他，我早就去某个岛上了。我直接带着奥利弗·诺斯的所有钱逃跑了。所以这就是其中一部分。
That's an element. That's quite bad because that's illegal. That's running an illegal foreign policy. What makes this so baroque is that at the same time, Bud McFarlane, National Security Advisor, he's contacted by the Israelis. And the Israelis say to him, listen, we've identified what we think is a moderate faction
这是一个要素。这相当糟糕，因为这是违法的。这是在推行非法的外交政策。让这一切变得如此离奇的是，与此同时，国家安全顾问巴德·麦克法兰被以色列人联系了。以色列人对他说：“听着，我们发现了我们认为在伊朗内部存在的一个温和派派系。”
in iran so on the other side of the world the ayatollah's regime a moderate faction that we think would be open to a deal with the americans in the long run and they would be very interested in using their influence to free american hostages being held in lebanon by hezbollah because the americans had made a disastrous, under Reagan, the Marines had been blown up, hadn't they, by a car bomb. More than 200 in a car bomb in Lebanon, and then they left again. And as revenge, Hezbollah started kidnapping Americans. These go-betweens say, listen, these Iranians can probably use their influence.
在世界的另一边，阿亚图拉政权中的一个温和派派系，我们认为长远来看他们可能对与美国达成协议持开放态度，并且他们会对利用其影响力解救被真主党关押在黎巴嫩的美国人质非常感兴趣，因为在里根执政期间，美国人犯下了一个灾难性的错误，海军陆战队员被汽车炸弹炸毁了，不是吗？在黎巴嫩的一次汽车炸弹袭击中有200多人丧生，然后他们又撤离了。作为报复，真主党开始绑架美国人。这些中间人说：“听着，这些伊朗人或许可以利用他们的影响力。”
However, the quid pro quo is, they would like weapons to use in their war against Iraq, against Saddam Hussein. Armed shipments. In return, they'll release the hostages. Now, the problem with this is the US is sponsoring an arms embargo against the Iranian regime, who are their great enemies. However, when they take this to Reagan, Reagan's just had an operation, so he's very groggy. I think he's still compos mentis.
然而，交换条件是，他们想要武器来打他们与伊拉克的战争，也就是对抗萨达姆·侯赛因。武器运送。作为回报，他们将释放人质。现在，这里的问题在于，美国正在赞助一项针对伊朗政权的武器禁运，而伊朗是他们的大敌。然而，当他们把这件事呈报给里根时，里根刚做完手术，所以还很不清醒。我想他当时还是神志清醒的。
In August 1985, he says, I think this is a great idea, because he's like Jimmy Carter before him. He feels a real personal responsibility about the hostages. He's desperate to get them home, absolutely obsessed by them. And one of them was station chief in Beirut. Yes. Yeah. But not all. I mean, some of them are sort of, there's a priest and there's journalists, all these
在1985年8月，他说：“我认为这是一个绝妙的主意。”因为他就像他之前的吉米·卡特一样。他对人质有一种真正的个人责任感。他极度渴望让他们回家，对他们简直到了痴迷的地步。其中一个人还是贝鲁特的站长。是的。是的。但并非全部。我的意思是，其中有一些是，有一个牧师，还有记者，所有这些
kinds of things. His more sort of sober advisors, so George Shultz, the Secretary of State, Caspar Weinberger, Secretary of Defense, they say to him, this is an absolutely ludicrous and terrible idea. There's nothing good in this idea at all. He says, no, go for it. Do it. So McFarlane and again, Oliver North, they get in touch with a go-between. Here's a man called Manusha Ghorbanifah. The CIA described him in print, had written down, he is an intelligence fabricator and a nuisance, a con artist. He's the kind of person who'd send you an email saying he's just been robbed in the Philippines. And can you send your bank details?
类型的人。他那些比较清醒的顾问们，比如国务卿乔治·舒尔茨，国防部长卡斯帕·温伯格，对他说：“这是一个绝对荒谬且糟糕透顶的主意。这个主意里一点好处也没有。”他说：“不，去吧。干吧。”于是麦克法兰还有奥利弗·诺斯，他们联系了一个中间人。这里有一个人叫曼努谢尔·戈尔巴尼法（Manouchehr Ghorbanifar）。中情局在印刷品中对他的描述是：他是一个情报捏造者和讨厌鬼、骗子。他就是那种会给你发一封电子邮件说他在菲律宾刚被抢劫了的人。你能汇点银行账号信息过去吗？
Yes, please send your bank details. Don't write down the wrong bank details and they'll go to the Swiss bloke. They ignore this. So they start to organize these arms shipments to Iran via the Israelis, anti-tank missiles. As time goes on, so 1985 is beginning to turn into 1986, the Iranians just say, yeah, we haven't quite got around to releasing the hostages, but keep sending more of these arms, please. So they send these arms. They start to have to use CIA front airlines to to do it which is very illegal everything is sort of slut has this air of incompetence so at one point they send them some hawk missiles which turn out to have the star of david on them so the iranians say well those are useless because
是的，请发送您的银行账号。别写错了银行账号，不然钱会汇到那个瑞士家伙手里。他们无视了这一点。于是他们开始通过以色列人组织向伊朗运送这些武器，反坦克导弹。随着时间的推移，1985年开始转入1986年，伊朗人只是说：“是的，我们还没完全抽出时间释放人质，但请继续运送更多这种武器。”于是他们运送了这些武器。他们开始不得不使用中情局的幌子公司来完成这项工作，这非常违法，所有事情都有一种无能的气息。所以有一次他们送去了一些霍克导弹，结果上面竟然有大卫之星的标志，于是伊朗人说：“这些根本没用，因为
we can't use those um you'll have to just send more and and and it's sort of in for a penny in for a pound so north and co they keep sort of saying well we'll have to send more you know we're in for it now just a few thousand more missiles and all this sort of stuff so by the turn of 1986 i mean there's you know a plan um they're going to send the iranians 4 000 anti-tank missiles in a series of shipments and with each shipment the the Iranians will release a hostage. Now, this is discussed in the White House. So even though it's breaking the embargo, it's like a secret foreign policy that's going against your overt foreign policy. Reagan is listening to all this. Schultz and Weinberger keep saying,
我们无法使用那些，呃，你们只能再送一些来。”而且这属于“豁出去干了”，所以诺斯和库普他们不断地说：“好吧，我们得再送一些，你知道的，我们现在已经陷进去了。”只要再多几千枚导弹和诸如此类的事情。所以在1986年转折之际，我的意思是，有一个计划，他们打算分批向伊朗运送4000枚反坦克导弹，每运送一批，伊朗人就会释放一名人质。现在，这在白宫进行了讨论。因此，尽管这违反了禁运，但这就像是一项违背你公开外交政策的秘密外交政策。里根听取了所有这些。舒尔茨和温伯格不断地说：
these are terrible, terrible ideas. Why are we doing this? And Reagan always says, do it. And he says to Weinberg at one point, we're doing this for the hostages. I don't want people to say I wasn't a big enough man to do everything in my power to get the hostages back. But it's about this point that Oliver North, full of bullshit as he's been described, has a brainwave. Why don't we overcharge the Iranians for the arms? Then I'll use the profits to give that money to the Contras. So he starts doing that and he's got $12 million and he's funneling the profits to Nicaragua. So it's illegal in two ways now, so in Iran and in the Central American dimension. Still, the hostages are not all being released.
这些全都是糟糕透顶的主意。我们为什么要这么做？而里根总是说：“照办。”他有一次对温伯格说：“我们这么做是为了人质。我不想让别人说我没有足够的胸襟去尽我所能把人质解救回来。”但正是在这个时候，满嘴跑火车的奥利弗·诺斯灵光一现。为什么我们不把武器的价格抬高卖给伊朗人呢？然后我可以用这些利润把钱给“康特拉”。于是他开始这么做了，他弄到了1200万美元，并把这些利润输送到尼加拉瓜。所以现在它在两个方面都是违法的——在伊朗维度和中美洲维度。尽管如此，人质并没有全部被释放。
In an absolutely ludicrous development in May 1986, in an attempt to sort of break the deadlock, Bud McFarlane and Oliver North actually fly to Iran. Is this when they take the Bible? On Irish passports, fake Irish passports. I mean, it's absolutely mind-boggling that they thought they could get away with this. They fly into Iran on Irish passports carrying two pistols,
在1986年5月一个绝对荒谬的发展中，为了打破僵局，巴德·麦克法兰和奥利弗·诺斯竟然真的飞往了伊朗。这就是他们带《圣经》的那次吗？使用爱尔兰护照，假的爱尔兰护照。我的意思是，他们居然认为自己能蒙混过关，这简直令人匪夷所思。他们拿着爱尔兰护照飞进伊朗
which are immediately confiscated by the Iranian security or customs people, a chocolate cake that they had bought from a kosher bakery in Tel Aviv, and a Bible personally inscribed by Ronald Reagan. I mean, how they could think. They turn up anyway with all this stuff. And the Iranians don't send anyone to meet them it's completely obvious that they've been the victims of a terrible scam i mean the iranians do send junior people but not senior people and after i think four days they fly home sans chocolate cake but you see they could very easily not have flown home i mean they could have been taken hostage they could have been taken so it's quite courageous but mad putting your head in a crocodile's mouth yes putting a your head in a crocodile's mouth.
随身携带了两把手枪——这立刻被伊朗的安全或海关人员没收了，一个他们从特拉维夫的一家犹太洁食面包店买的巧克力蛋糕，以及一本由罗克·里根亲笔签名的《圣经》。我的意思是，他们怎么会这么想。无论如何，他们带着所有这些东西出现了。伊朗人根本没有派任何人去迎接他们，完全显而易见的是，他们成了一场可怕骗局的受害者。我的意思是，伊朗人确实派了一些低级别的官员，但不是高级官员。在我想象大约四天后，他们飞回家了，没有带巧克力蛋糕。但你看，他们完全有可能回不了家——我的意思是，他们本可能被扣为人质，他们本可能被抓走。所以这相当勇敢，但也极其疯狂，把头伸进鳄鱼嘴里。是的，把头伸进鳄鱼嘴里。
Yes, putting a chocolate cake in a crocodile's mouth. Exactly. Then in October 1986, a plane is shot down over... It's got a bit of Watergate about this, hasn't it? It really does.
是的，把一块巧克力蛋糕放进鳄鱼嘴里。完全正确。接着在1986年10月，一架飞机在……被击落了。这有点像“水门事件”的感觉，不是吗？确实如此。
Yeah, definitely. A sort of ludicrous incompetence. A plane is shot down in Nicaragua. The pilot is a man called Eugene Hassenfuss. Again, slightly, you couldn't make it up name.
是的，绝对是的。一种荒谬的无能。一架飞机在尼加拉瓜被击落。飞行员是一个叫尤金·哈森弗斯（Eugene Hasenfus）的人。同样，这又是个你编都编不出来的名字。
I looked him up. He was recently in trouble for exposing himself in a Walmart, Tom. Was he? Yeah. Anyway, he basically talks to the Nicaraguans who shot him down. Oh, I'm working for the CIA. At that point, the whole story breaks. The Lebanese newspaper breaks the story about the Iranian trip. Oliver North desperately tries to shred all the papers. And this is all his secretary, Fawn Hall. Fawn Hall, she stuffs them down her blouse. I mean, Oliver North is the absolute spit of a plucky Marine doing his bit for Uncle Sam in a Central American dictatorship.
我查过他。他最近因为在沃尔玛裸露身体而惹上麻烦了，汤姆。是吗？是的。无论如何，他基本上向击落他的尼加拉瓜人交代了：“哦，我在为中情局工作。”就在那时，整个事件曝光了。一家黎巴嫩报纸爆出了伊朗之行的内幕。奥利弗·诺斯拼命试图粉碎所有的文件。而这一切都是由他的秘书福恩·霍尔（Fawn Hall）完成的。福恩·霍尔，她把文件塞进衬衫里。我的意思是，奥利弗·诺斯简直就是为了山姆大叔在中美洲独裁统治中尽职尽责的一个勇敢的海兵的翻版。
And Fawn Hall not only has the name, but has the big hair of a typecast mid-1980s. She's kind of Melanie Griffiths in Working Girl. She'd be in Dallas or Dynasty, as our American listeners would call it. She absolutely is. So she's stuffing this stuff down her bra or stuffing it into her boots, the papers.
而福恩·霍尔不仅名字符合，还顶着一头典型20世纪80年代中期风格的大波浪发型。她有点像是《打工女郎》（Working Girl）里的梅兰妮·格里菲斯。她会出现在《达拉斯》或《豪门恩怨》（Dynasty）里，就像我们的美国听众所称呼的那样。她绝对是的。所以她把这些东西塞进胸罩里，或者把文件塞进靴子里。
North, they shred something like two, I don't know, two square feet of documents or something. But he forgets that he does the documents from his own filing cabinet, but he forgets that they're just copies and Fauna Hall has all the originals, and he hasn't shredded those. During investigations, everything goes wrong. McFarlane actually tried to kill himself before his own testimony. The boss of the CIA, Bill Casey, who's about 180, has a seizure on his way to Capitol Hill to testify.
诺斯，他们粉碎了大约两平方英尺左右的文件。但他忘记了——他是从自己的档案柜里拿出文件的，但他忘记了那些只是复印件，而福恩·霍尔拥有所有的原件，他并没有把那些粉碎掉。在调查期间，一切都出了岔子。麦克法兰在作证前甚至试图自杀。中情局局长比尔·凯西（Bill Casey），大约有180岁了，在去国会山作证的路上突然中风。
And then it turns out he's got a brain tumor that kills him. And Reagan denies the whole thing. I mean, Reagan undoubtedly, and there's no two ways of putting it, Reagan lies about it. Reagan says, I didn't know anything about it. Well, or so he ends up with Alzheimer's. Yes. And people have discussed, haven't they, whether that is starting to kick in at this point,
后来发现他得了脑瘤，并因此丧命。而里根则全面否认此事。我的意思是，里根毫无疑问——这是毋庸置疑的——里根在这件事上撒了谎。里根说：“我对此一无所知。”嗯，或者说他最终得了阿尔茨海默病。是的。人们也讨论过，不是吗，这是否在当时已经开始发作了，
whether he genuinely is forgetting these kind of details. I mean, Reagan's never been a details man, I suppose it's fair to say. And he's also, we talked a bit before, haven't we, about how he creates his own truth. Yeah. Not unlike other residents of California, of course, in their own time. He creates his own truth in which he strongly believes. I mean, there's that denial that I mentioned at the beginning. My heart, my best intentions still tell me that it's true, but the facts and the evidence tell me it's not. I mean, people are sort of saying to him, Mr. President,
他是否真的在逐渐忘记这些细节。我的意思是，里根从来都不是一个关注细节的人，这样说算公道吧。而且他也是——我们之前讨论过，不是吗？——关于他是如何创造自己的真相的。是的。当然，这与其他加州居民在他们那个时代不无相似之处。他创造了自己深信不疑的真相。我的意思是，正如我一开始提到的那种否认：我的心，我最好的意图仍然告诉我这是真的，但事实和证据告诉我并非如此。我的意思是，人们对他说：“总统先生，
you signed off on this. We have pieces of paper. Now, he didn't know, I think, people are sort of saying to him, Mr. President, you signed off on this. You know, we have pieces of paper. Now, he didn't know, I think, about the linkage between Iran. And there's no evidence that he knew about that North was using the profits from one to fund the other. But he had explicitly said, do what you can to fund the Contras and had explicitly given the go ahead for the arms for hostages deal. There's no doubt about that whatsoever. So how does he avoid a Watergate situation then?
你在文件上签了字。我们有文件证据。”现在，我认为他不知道——人们对他说：“总统先生，你在文件上签了字。你知道的，我们有文件证据。”现在，我认为他不知道关于伊朗之间的联系。并且没有证据表明他知道诺斯在利用一边的利润来资助另一边。但他曾明确表示过：“尽你所能资助‘康特拉’”，并明确批准了武器换人质的交易。这一点毫无疑问。那么他是如何避开水门事件式的困境的呢？
One, because there's already been Watergate. So people are- They want to bring down a second president. They don't want to bring down a second president so soon. Two, I think his personal, his administration is anyway approaching the fag end. Yeah. So in a way he can kind of get away with it.
第一，因为已经有过水门事件了。所以人们——他们不想推翻第二位总统。他们不想这么快就推翻第二位总统。第二，我认为他个人的、他的政府无论如何也接近强弩之末了。是的，所以在某种程度上他可以蒙混过关。
I think his own personal charm- So he's more popular than nixon yeah he hasn't got as many enemies maybe as nixon people who are people are itching to bring nixon down in a way they're not with reagan and yet i think i mean i always remember when i first studied this as a student my then supervisor said to me iran contra was so much of a bigger deal than watergate yeah it sounds like irContra is running two illegal foreign policies. And shoveling money to Iran. Yeah. I mean, it's a massive deal. Whereas Watergate was famously a third rate burglary. Yeah. So a complex story. Yeah. Brilliantly told. Well, I don't know about brilliantly told, but told very quickly. Brilliantly told.
我认为他个人的魅力——所以他比尼克松更受欢迎？是的，他可能没有尼克松那么多敌人，那些急于把尼克松拉下马的人并没有像对待里根那样对待他。然而，我想——我总是记得当我作为学生第一次学习这段历史时，我当时的导师对我说：伊朗-康特拉事件比水门事件要重大得多。是的，听起来伊朗-康特拉事件是在推行两项非法的外国政策，并向伊朗倾倒资金。是的。我的意思是，这是一件极其重大事情。而水门事件按理说只是一起三流的盗窃案。是的。所以这是一个复杂的故事。是的。讲述得非常精彩。好吧，我不知道算不算讲述得精彩，但讲得非常快。讲述得非常精彩。
So the other big aspect of Reagan's second term, which shows him in a much better light, is his dealings with gorbachev and it's written in the stars this is going to go well because before reagan goes to see gorbachev for the first time in geneva nancy reagan's astrologer does gorbachev's horoscope oh and it's all going to be fine joanne quigley yeah joan quickly yeah so that's good oh that's very good well geneva actually so he has four summits with gorbachev geneva reykjavik washington moscow and reykjavik he's staying in the former um british ambassador's house he has been in it's very bleak apparently tom very bleak and the
所以里根第二个任期的另一个重大方面，这让他以好得多的形象出现，那就是他与戈尔巴乔夫的交往。这就像命中注定一样一切都会顺利，因为在里根第一次去日内瓦见戈尔巴乔夫之前，南茜·里根的占星师就给戈尔巴乔夫做了星座运势。哦，一切都会没问题的。琼·奎格利（Joan Quigley）。是的，琼·奎格利。是的，那太好了。哦，那太棒了。好吧，日内瓦实际上——所以他与戈尔巴乔夫举行了四次峰会：日内瓦、雷克雅未克、华盛顿、莫斯科。在雷克雅未克，他住在前英国大使的房子里。他住进过那里，显然非常荒凉，汤姆，非常荒凉，而且
british ambassador got rid of it because he said it was haunted frankly haunted by the ghost of disarmament talks to come so geneva they have a meeting it meeting. It's quite frosty. There's no deal. However, they do have a bit of a rapport. So they can talk to each other as human beings and they do argue about their respective systems. Reagan's got all his kind of reading in Human Events and Reader's Digest that he's been doing by this stage for what 30 years 40 years so he's full of the communist system and he can't he actually at one point later on washington he tries out some of his anti-russian jokes on gorbachev yeah in the oval office right and this massive embarrassment all around i mean all the americans say it was awful and they wished the ground would swallow
英国大使之所以搬走是因为他说那里闹鬼，坦率地说，闹着未来裁军会谈的鬼魂。所以他们在日内瓦开了一次会。会议相当冷淡。没有达成任何协议。然而，他们确实建立了一点默契。因此他们能够像人类一样交流，并且他们确实就各自的制度进行了争论。里根读过所有他在《人类事件》（Human Events）和《读者文摘》（Reader's Digest）上读到的东西，到这个时候他已经读了多少年了？30年，40年？所以他满脑子都是关于共产主义制度的看法，甚至在后来华盛顿的某个时刻，他还在椭圆形办公室里对戈尔巴乔夫开起了他那几个反俄的玩笑。对，就在椭圆形办公室里。这让周围所有人陷入了极大的尴尬。所有的美国人都说这太糟糕了，恨不得地上裂个缝钻进去。
them up yeah and because gorbachev doesn't laugh at all. Reykjavik is the key one, because although they don't get a deal in Reykjavik, Gorbachev goes in with a massive, massive offer of 50% cuts in their nuclear weapons and get rid of all their intermediate weapons, which are their sort of range of about 2,000 to 4,000 miles. Unbelievably, Reagan then says, well, why don't we get rid of all of them? Why don't we get rid of them of them? Why don't we get rid of them all? And in the end, it's Star Wars that's the sticking point. It's Star Wars that brings it down because Reagan is so committed to Star Wars. Gorbachev hates the
是的，因为戈尔巴乔夫根本没有笑。雷克雅未克是关键所在，因为尽管他们在雷克雅未克没有达成协议，但戈尔巴乔夫带着一个巨大无比的提议去了，即削减50%的核武器，并废除所有中程武器，也就是射程在大约2000到4000英里之间的武器。令人难以置信的是，里根接着说：“嗯，为什么我们不把它们全部废除呢？为什么我们不把它们全都废除呢？为什么我们不把它们全部废除呢？”最后，“星球大战”计划成了症结所在。是“星球大战”让谈判破裂，因为里根对“星球大战”太执着了。戈尔巴乔夫痛恨
thought of Star Wars. Historians have different views about this, about how much Reagan's defense spending put pressure on the Russians. There's no doubt that Gorbachev was genuinely concerned about Star Wars. I mean, actually, the irony is they spent all that money, billions and billions, but it never came to fruition. But it's sort of psychologically, I think it hammers home to the Soviet leadership how backward they are. By comparison, they can't possibly keep up. But Reagan left Reykjavik devastated. So if you think that Reagan was already... If you think back to when we were talking before about Reagan, how deep seated his horror of nuclear weapons is. And this idealistic dream, which actually horrifies not just a lot of his staff.
“星球大战”的想法。历史学家对此有不同的看法，关于里根的国防开支给俄国人施加了多大压力。毫无疑问，戈尔巴乔夫确实对“星球大战”感到担忧。我的意思是，实际上，具有讽刺意味的是，他们花了那么多钱，数百亿美元，但它从未实现。但从心理上讲，我认为这向苏联领导层狠狠地敲响了警钟，让他们意识到自己落后了多少。相比之下，他们根本无法跟上。但里根离开雷克雅未克时心碎欲绝。所以如果你认为里根当时已经……回想一下我们之前讨论里根的时候，他内心对核武器的恐惧是多么根深蒂固。还有那种理想主义的梦想，这实际上不仅惊吓了他的许多幕僚。
But Mrs. Thatcher. Yeah. All his allies. Yeah. What would have happened if he'd agreed, do you think? I don't think he would have been allowed to agree, actually. They would have read it back. I think so. The president misspoke. Yeah.
还有撒切尔夫人。是的。他所有的盟友。是的。你认为如果他当时同意了，会发生什么？事实上，我认为他根本不会被允许同意。他们会要求他收回成命。我认为是这样的。“总统失言了。”是的。
People within his own administration got in touch with Mrs. Thatcher and said, I have terrible news. He's offered to give away. I mean, this genuinely happened. They said, he's offered to give away all our nuclear weapons. You must use your influence. Get on the phone to him. You know, tell him.
他自己政府内部的人联系了撒切尔夫人，说：“我有一个可怕的消息。他提议放弃一切。”我的意思是，这确实发生了。他们说：“他提议放弃我们所有的核武器。你必须利用你的影响力。给他打电话。你知道，告诉他——”
For Christ's sake, don't go. Because they then think, because in Europe, people say, well, we're undefended. The Russians could walk in, the Red Army could just come over the border at any point, and we have no defense. Reagan is sort of devastated by this. The interesting thing is, how much credit do you give to Reagan personally for the thawing? The truth of the matter is, almost any other US president would have had a much harder time, because they would have got such a beating from the conservatives in the United States as selling out. But because Reagan has these anti-communist credentials, he actually does get a bit of flack from conservative periodicals who say, unbelievable, Ronald Reagan of all people has fallen for the communist lie. But he's simultaneously playing good cop and
“看在上帝的份上，别答应。”因为他们随后会想，在欧洲，人们会说：“好吧，我们毫无防备。俄国人可以长驱直入，红军随时可能越过边境，而我们没有任何防御。”里根对此感到万分沮丧。有趣的是，你认为里根个人在冰释前嫌中起了多大作用？事实的真相是，几乎任何其他美国总统都会过得更加艰难，因为他们会遭到美国保守派的狂轰滥炸，被指责为出卖国家。但因为里根拥有这些反共的资历，他实际上虽然也从保守派期刊那里遭到了一些抨击，说：“难以置信，罗纳德·里根竟然会相信共产主义的谎言。”但他同时在扮演红脸和
bad cop, isn't he? So he goes to Moscow and he kind of hangs out and all that kind of stuff yeah in red square is that what he does tom is that the noise that's exactly what he does and then he goes to berlin yeah and says mr garbage have pulled down that wall tear down this wall yeah you've got it's berlin first then moscow but you're right he is doing that he's putting on the pressure right bad cop good cop then bad cop good cop exactly he's he's putting on the pressure they do sign a treaty in, good cop then. Bad cop, good cop. Exactly. He's putting on the pressure. They do sign a treaty in Washington, the INF Treaty. They begin the process of strategic arms reduction. And he goes to Moscow, and that really is such a psychological moment. Because somebody says to him as he's walking around in Red Square, greeting the crowds, do you still think this is an evil empire, Mr. Reagan?
白脸，不是吗？所以他去莫斯科，在那儿闲逛，做诸如此类的事，是的，在红场，他是这么做的吗，汤姆？这就是那个动静？这正是他所做的，然后他去柏林，是的，说：“戈尔巴乔夫先生，推倒这堵墙！拆毁这堵墙！”是的，你猜对了，先是柏林，然后是莫斯科。但你是对的，他确实在这么做。他在施加压力，红脸白脸，然后白脸红脸，红脸白脸，完全正确。他在施加压力。他们确实在华盛顿签署了一项条约，即《中导条约》（INF Treaty）。他们开启了战略武器削减的进程。他去了莫斯科，那真的是一个极具心理冲击力的时刻。因为当他在红场散步、向人群致意时，有人问他：“你还认为这是一个邪恶帝国吗，里根先生？”
And he says, that was another time, another era. I mean, personally, I would say it's not so much that Reagan won the Cold War, but that Gorbachev chose no longer to fight it. I think that was the key to it. But I think any other US president without Reagan's credentials would have had a much harder time. And I think the symbolism was all the greater coming with Reagan. And Reagan, having put so much rhetorical pressure on the Soviet Union, certainly in his first term and then before that, before his presidency, meant that it gave him the freedom to be able to strike a deal and to be warm with Gorbachev
而他说：“那是另一个时代，另一个纪元。”就我个人而言，我会说与其说是里根赢得了冷战，不如说是戈尔巴乔夫选择不再打了。我认为这才是关键所在。但我认为，任何其他没有里根资历的美国总统都会过得艰难得多。而且我认为，由里根来做这一切，其象征意义要重大得多。里根在第一任期内以及在此之前、在总统任期之前，对苏联施加了如此巨大的言论压力，这意味着这赋予了他能够达成协议、对戈尔巴乔夫表现热情、
and to stroll around shaking hands in the Arbat in Moscow. For any other American president, the backlash at home would have been massive, but Reagan was able to get away with it. So, Dominic, we're approaching the end. Yeah. If we were to kind of draw up the account book. Yeah. Reagan ceases to be president.
以及在莫斯科阿尔巴特街漫步握手的自由。换作任何其他美国总统，国内的反弹都会是巨大的，但里根却能侥幸过关。所以，多米尼克，我们接近尾声了。是的。如果我们来盘点一下帐目。是的。里根不再担任总统。
He's succeeded by George Herbert Bush, who had been his vice president for the previous eight years. George Herbert Walker Bush. Don't forget the Walker. George Herbert Walker Bush. He retires to California. He's diagnosed with Alzheimer's. Yes. And he dies in 2004.
接替他的是乔治·赫伯特·布希，他在此前的八年里一直担任副总统。乔治·赫伯特·沃克·布希。别忘了“沃克”。乔治·赫伯特·沃克·布希。他退休回到加州。他被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病。是的。他于2004年去世。
The impression I get is that in America, even those who are very ideologically opposed to what he did, I mean, he's not hated in the way that a lot of, I mean, pretty much all the subsequent presidents are. So I don't think people actually feel very strongly about the first George Bush, but Clinton, second Bush, Obama, Trump, Biden. I mean, they've all been massively, massively polarizing figures. Whereas Reagan has, I guess he was a very polarizing figure in his own time, but even his opponents kind of, they liked him. They seem to have liked him. So Tip O'Neill, you mentioned Tip O'Neill to have liked him so tip o'neill you mentioned tip o'neill is a great example tip o'neill was the speaker of the house he was implacably opposed to everything reagan stood for but tip o'neill says doesn't he um it's quoted in bob spitzer's book that we've referred to a few times reagan would have made a brilliant monarch
我的印象是，在美国，即使是那些在意识形态上极力反对他所作所为的人——我的意思是，他并没有遭到那种许多——我的意思是，几乎所有后来的总统都遭遇过的那种仇恨。所以我不认为人们对老布希有那么强烈的负面情绪，但克林顿、小布希、奥巴马、特朗普、拜登，我的意思是，他们全都是极具极化色彩的人物。然而里根——我想他在他那个时代也是一个极具极化色彩的人物，但即使是他的对手也某种程度上——他们喜欢他。他们似乎挺喜欢他的。比如蒂普·奥尼尔，你提到过蒂普·奥尼尔，他就是一个很好的例子。蒂普·奥尼尔是众议院议长，他坚决反对里根代表的一切，但蒂普·奥尼尔说过，不是吗？鲍勃·斯皮策（Bob Spitzer）的书里引用过这一点，我们已经引用过好几次了：“里根会成为一个绝妙的君主。”
i mean that is an important part of being a president isn't it that the monarchical role that he does seem to have done brilliantly. But in terms of policy, perhaps setting the Cold War policy, the rapprochement with Gorbachev aside, his presidency seemed marked by a series of scandals, gaffes, failures, massive deficits. Yeah, that would be the harsh view. If you're a more right-leaning economist, you might say the Reagan tax cuts established the foundations from which the American economy then booms in the 80s and 90s. I mean, I'm not going to pronounce a judgment on that, because actually, I think that just comes down to personal political predilections
我的意思是，那是作为一个总统的重要部分，不是吗？那种他似乎做得极其出色的君主角色。但在政策方面，撇开冷战政策和与戈尔巴乔夫的和解不谈，他的总统任期似乎以一系列丑闻、失言、失败和巨额赤字为标志。是的，这会是比较严厉的看法。如果你是一个更倾向右翼的经济学家，你可能会说里根的减税政策为美国经济在80年代和90年代的繁荣奠定了基础。我的意思是，我不会对此做出评判，因为实际上，我认为这很大程度上取决于个人的政治偏好。
as much as anything. I think Reagan definitely restores the prestige of the presidency after the Nixon. And of America. And of America, I think undoubtedly. You can't dismiss those things. And most historians, even liberal historians who've written about this say, there's no doubt that he's a brilliant advertisement for the American brand. But this goes back to what we've been saying all along, that the image, the brand, the roles that he's playing, the vibe is a crucial part of what makes him an important and significant president. And that it is a mistake to sneer at that.
我认为里根在尼之后确实恢复了总统职位的威望。以及美国的威望，我认为毫无疑问。你不能忽视这些。大多数历史学家，甚至写过关于这方面的自由派历史学家都说，毫无疑问，他是美国品牌的绝佳代言人。但这可以追溯到我们一直以来的观点，即形象、品牌、他扮演的角色、那种氛围，是让他成为一个重要且意义重大的总统的关键部分。嘲笑这一点是错误的。
I think it's definitely a mistake. Because actually, it's a very important part of being a president. The idea that being a president, I mean, especially being a president rather than a prime minister, the idea that being a president rather than a prime minister. The idea that you're a president is just a matter of poring over briefing books and understanding the nitty gritty of policy and line by line analysis of legislation. That's all there is to it is a massive, massive misunderstanding. A lot of being a president is doing exactly what Reagan was doing when he worked at General Electric.
我认为这绝对是错误的。因为实际上，这是当好总统非常重要的一部分。那种认为当总统——我的意思是，特别是当总统而不是当首相——那种认为当总统只是埋头苦读简报、理解政策细节、逐行分析立法，这就是全部内容的看法，是一个极其巨大的误解。当总统很大一部分工作就像里根在通用电气工作时做的那样。
It is going to the plants, making people feel good about themselves, telling them a few jokes, all that sort of stuff. I mean, FDR was very good at that, Reagan's hero. And FDR people said, he's shallow, he doesn't understand the policy. Clinton was very good at that too. Clinton was good at that, and Clinton definitely did understand the policy, but Clinton was more undisciplined than Reagan. Reagan had tremendous message discipline. When it worked, it worked very well. When he surrounded himself with pragmatic, bright people, he was an effective governor of California,
就是去工厂视察，让人们自我感觉良好，给他们讲几个笑话，诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，罗斯福（FDR）就很擅长这一点，他是里根的偶像。人们曾说罗斯福很肤浅，不懂政策。克林顿也很擅长这一点。克林顿很擅长，而且克林顿确实懂政策，但克林顿比里根更缺乏纪律性。里根有着极强的传达纪律。当它起作用时，效果非常好。当他身边环绕着务实、聪明的人时，他是一位高效的加州州长，
and there were definitely things that he gets right. And a good example of that is handling the Soviet Union. The economy, I mean, there's no doubt that he left massive deficits. And his economic mantra, I mean, I would say was, in a way, quite unconservative because it just relied so much on borrowing. So one last question. It's in the 80s that the tech boom happens.
而且他确实做对了很多事情。一个很好的例子就是处理对苏关系。至于经济，我的意思是，毫无疑问他留下了巨额赤字。而且他的经济口号，我的意思是，我会说在某种程度上相当不保守，因为它太依赖借贷了。所以最后一个问题。正是80年代，科技泡沫爆发了。
Yeah. Really starts to kick in in California, which has been the underpinning for so much of American influence and economic power into the 21st century. That's happening in California where Reagan was governor. It happens under his presidency can he lay any claim to having played a role in that or is that just you know that he is the surface froth and these deep kind of currents are moving beneath that surface for off i definitely wouldn't give him credit for the tech boom necessarily i would say
是的。开始在加州真正兴起，这成为了21世纪美国影响力和经济力量的重要基石。这一切都发生在里根担任州长的加州。这一切发生在他的总统任期内，他能为此居功至伟吗，还是说这只是——你知道的——他只是表面的泡沫，而这些深层的暗流在表面之下涌动？泡沫。我绝对不会把科技泡沫归功于他，我会说
because the tech boom really begins in the 70s and it's not because of his govern governorship in California at all. I mean, if you take Reagan out of the equation, the tech boom still happens. It's still going to happen. But I suppose, I think there's three ways in which he's obviously consequential. One is about, this will sound like a pejorative word, and I don't mean it that way, but as an American nationalist, making Americans feel good about their country, asserting their strength, their role in the world, all that. Number two is the relationship with Gorbachev. I think that undoubtedly is really, really important. And number three is he establishes a kind of, he is the Republican Roosevelt. He becomes a kind of model, a dream figure. So now all Republican candidates pay homage to Reagan. They evoke Reagan. Often without,
因为科技泡沫实际上在70年代就已经开始了，这根本不是因为他担任加州州长。我的意思是，如果你把里根从这个方程中拿掉，科技泡沫依然会发生。它还是会发生的。但我想，我认为他在三个方面显然具有重大影响。一是，这听起来可能是一个贬义词，但我不是这个意思——作为一个美国民族主义者，让美国人对自己的国家感到自豪，彰显他们的力量、他们在世界上的角色，等等。第二点是与戈尔巴乔夫的关系。我认为这毫无疑问非常非常重要。第三点是，他确立了一种——他是共和党的罗斯福。他成为了一种模范、一个梦想化身。所以现在所有的共和党候选人都向里根致敬。他们唤起里根的遗产。通常甚至不需要
I have to say, a massive understanding of his career and what he stood for, but he has become the touchstone. And there are not many presidents of whom that's true. And if, as some listeners may conclude at the end of this program, that's partly because he's a master of smoke and mirrors as much as of substance. I mean- Say what? Yeah. We've done podcasts and everything from the Roman emperors to medieval kings, and smoke and mirrors has always been a huge part of it, hasn't it? So, you know, Julius Caesar, who we did a podcast about a month ago, would Julius Caesar have looked at Ronald Reagan and said, what a shallow waste of space?
我必须得说，人们对他的职业生涯以及他所代表的理念有着深刻的理解，而且他已经成为了一个试金石。符合这一点的总统并不多。如果正如一些听众在本期节目最后可能得出的结论那样，这部分是因为他既是一个实质的创造者，也是一个幻术的大师。我的意思是——什么？是的。我们做过从罗马皇帝到中世纪国王的各种播客，而幻术一直是其中非常重要的一部分，不是吗？所以，比如说尤利乌斯·恺撒，我们一个月前刚做过关于他的播客，尤利乌斯·恺撒会看着罗纳德·里根然后说，真是个肤浅的草包吗？
Or would he have said, he's good? What do you think, Dom? I think he would have respected his talents as his ability to speak to the people. Yeah. I think the Romans would undoubtedly have recognized in Reagan, a familiar figure. Don't you think? Yeah, I think so.
还是会说，他真有一套？你觉得呢，多姆？我想他会敬佩里根的才能，以及他与民众对话的能力。是的。我想罗马人无疑会在里根身上认出一个熟悉的身影。你不觉得吗？是的，我也这么觉得。
All right. Well, on that note, Reagan, the Roman, I hadn't expected that we were going to end up with that conclusion. I thought you'd, after three episodes, Tom, something for you. Throw me a bone. Bless you. I don't think we should end with us though, should we? I think we should end with the man himself.
好吧，那就这样，罗马人里根，我本来没料到我们会得出这个结论。我还以为你会在三期节目之后，汤姆，给我留点面子呢。给我点安慰吧。保重。不过我觉得我们不应该以我们自己作为结束，对吧？我觉得我们应该以他本人作为结束。
The Gipper. With the Gipper. I think we should end with the Gipper. And Iipper. With the Gipper. I think we should end with the Gipper. And I think we have an authentic audio clip of the Gipper. His farewell address is January 1989, one of the most stirring and moving evocations of his faith in America. So take it away, please. Ronald Reagan.
吉普。伴随着吉普。我想我们应该以吉普结束。而且我想我们有一段关于吉普的真实音频片段。他1989年1月的告别演讲，对美国信念最激昂、最感人的唤起之一。那么请播放吧。罗纳德·里根。
I've spoken of the shining city all my political life, but I don't know if I ever quite communicated what I saw when I said it. But in my mind, it was a tall, proud city, built on rocks stronger than oceans, windswept, God-blessed, and teeming with people of all kinds living in harmony and peace, a city with free ports that hummed with commerce and creativity. And if there had to be city walls, the walls had doors, and the doors were open to anyone with the will and the heart to get here. That's how I saw it and see it still. And how stands the city on this winter night? More prosperous, more secure, and happier than it was eight years ago.
在我整个政治生涯中，我一直都在谈论那座闪耀的城市，但我不知道自己是否准确地传达了我当时心中的景象。但在我的脑海里，那是一座高大、骄傲的城市，建立在比海洋更坚硬的岩石之上，饱经风霜，受到上帝的祝福，到处都是形形色色生活在和谐与和平中的人们，这是一座拥有自由港口、充满商业活力与创造力的城市。如果有必要修建城墙，那城墙上也必须有门，而且这扇门向任何有意志和决心来到这里的人敞开。这就是我过去所见，如今依然所见的景象。那么，在这样一个冬夜，这座城市状况如何？比八年前更加繁荣、更加安全、更加幸福。
But more than that, after two hundred years, two centuries, she still stands strong and true on the Granite Ridge, and her glow has held steady no matter what storm. And she's still a beacon, still a magnet for all who must have freedom, for all the pilgrims from all the lost places who are hurtling through the darkness toward home. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
不仅如此，在经历了二百年、两个世纪之后，她依然坚固而真实地矗立在花岗岩岭上，无论经历什么风暴，她的光芒始终稳定。她依然是一座灯塔，依然是一块磁铁，吸引着所有渴望自由的人，吸引着所有从迷失之地飞奔而来、在黑暗中冲向家园的朝圣者。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。